Es imposible hablar de política en
estados unidos sin mencionar a esos
lobbies que presionan a los políticos
para que saquen leyes que les benefician.
Sin embargo fuera de este país los lobbies
son como los fans de justin bieber
todo el mundo sabe que existen pero
nadie los ha visto.
De hecho, en España es muy raro ver al
representante de algún lobby salir por
algún medio de comunicación.
Sin embargo, ¿son tan poderosos los
lobbies en Estados Unidos como nos los
pintan las series de televisión? ¿O
realmente es en Europa y en
latinoamérica donde tiene más poder
precisamente porque nadie los conoce ?Hoy
vamos a contestar a esa pregunta pero
primero vamos a daros un poquito de
perspectiva histórica.
En realidad los lobbies son tan antiguos
como la política misma. En la edad media
las clases profesionales se agrupaban en
torno a gremios para tener más poder de
influencia frente a los reyes. En el
norte de europa tenemos el caso de la
liga hanseática que fue el primer caso
de asociación transnacional de
comerciantes. Los miembros de la Hansa
eran mercaderes alemanes, suecos,
holandeses o incluso estonios. En su momento de máximo
poder consiguieron que el rey de
Dinamarca les concediera el monopolio de
todo el comercio de Escandinavia. Pero en
el lobby tal  y como lo conocemos hoy en
día
nace con la democracia en Estados Unidos
y ¿por qué? Pues porque de repente el
gobierno estaba obligando a escuchar al
pueblo.
Es más, en la Constitución
estadounidense se reconoce por primera
vez el llamado derecho de petición, que
significa que cualquier ciudadano puede
exigir información al parlamento e
incluso a sugerir cambios y compensaciones
legales. Es decir, que todos los
ciudadanos tienen derecho a influir en
la toma de decisiones políticas.
Es más, el término lobby en inglés
significa sala de espera y viene de la
época del presidente Ulysses S. Grant.
Este señor era un jugador empedernido
al que su mujer le prohibía
terminantemente encender puros en la
Casa Blanca,
así que cada vez que quería fumar se
tenía que ir a la sala de espera y
todos los que querían hablar con él
estaban ahí, ya, esperándole dispuestos a
invitarles a una copita de brandy
y a un buen cigarro. Poco a poco, las
empresas, pero también los sindicatos,
se dieron cuenta de que merecía la pena
invertir un poquito de dinero en tener a
profesionales a tiempo completo
contratados para estar en Washington y
relacionarse con los políticos.
Así es como nació todo un sector
económico que hoy en día da trabajo
sólo en esta ciudad a más de 10.000
personas.
Casi todo el trabajo de un lobbista consiste
en informar a los políticos sobre temas
concretos. Pensad que un diputado que
tenga que sacar una nueva regulación
para las farmacias no tiene por qué saber
nada sobre el sector farmacéutico y
sobre la medicina, y ahí es cuando llega,
por ejemplo, el representante de Pfizer y
le expone su punto de vista; y después
llega el del sindicato de médicos y le
da otra perspectiva alternativa. Porque
¡ojo! no os olvidéis de que hay muchísimos
lobbies en cada sector y muchos de
ellas pueden tener puntos de vista
totalmente antagónicos.
Es decir, el lobby tiene también su
parte buena.
¿Cuál es el problema? Pues que en muchos
casos los lobbistas quieren sobornar a
los políticos.
- "Abramoff pagó varios viajes a un
congresista, incluido uno a escocia,  y le
Signatures, donde todas las bebidas
las pagaba la casa". Y lo peor es que este
tipo de políticas no son para nada
excepcionales.   - "Llegamos a tener una
fuerte influencia en alrededor de 100
políticos en su momento". Por eso, en
el año 1992 el congreso americano sacó
la primera ley de transparencia de lobbies.
Por fin una ley prohibía expresamente
que un político aceptará regalos o
viajes pagados, pero lo más importante
fue la creación de un registro
obligatorio de lobistas. Es decir, que
cualquiera que quiera influir en un
político tiene que dar su nombre,
decir para quién trabaja,
qué intereses representa y cuáles son
sus cometidos. Y no sólo eso, además, los
políticos están obligados a informar
de las reuniones que mantienen con cada
persona. Precisamente, por eso, es tan
fácil hablar de lobbies en Estados Unidos.
Los lobistas salen por la televisión,
cualquiera puede ver para quién
trabajan, cuánto dinero ganan y
cuánto dinero se gastan.
De hecho en la descripción os he
dejado un par de links muy
interesantes donde lo podéis consultar.
Sin embardo, esto no evita que ocurran
cosas como esta: -"Fowler deja la casa blanca
para trabajar como lobbista para Johnson
and Johnson". Efectivamente, a falta de
sobornos que mejor que ofrecer salarios
millonarios a cambio de firmar una ley.
Por eso, desde el año 2007
cada vez que un político en Estados
Unidos deja su cargo tiene que pasar
como mínimo un año en lo que llaman "el
frigorífico" antes de poder trabajar
para un lobby. Por supuesto que estas
leyes no son la panacea y no pueden
evitar que ocurran casos de corrupción,
pero por lo que vamos a ver ahora
Estados Unidos tiene una ley bastante
mejor que la que vemos en otros países.
El registro obligatorio de lobbistas se
ha convertido en una tradición en todos
los países angloparlantes: Reino Unido,
Canadá, Australia, en todos estos sitios
hay un registro público que se puede
consultar por internet.
Sin embargo, en el resto del mundo apenas
están controlados, por ejemplo, Colombia
o España ni siquiera tienen un registro,
y en la Unión Europea
este censo es voluntario. Es decir, que si
un político quiere mantener una
reunión en secreto puede hacerlo y
nadie puede echarle nada en cara. Y por
eso es muy fácil pensar que Europa
está libre de lobbies o que sólo nos
afectan a aquellos que defienden el bien
común. -"Pero el bien común para ti es
una cosa, pero cuando te digan que por mi
bien común tienes que quedarte sin
comer y sin trabajar tu y tus cuatro hijos
de tu mujer tu concepto de bien común
cambia". Sin embargo, las cifras están
ahí. Como os decía antes,
en Washington hay más de 10.000
lobbistas registrados; en Bruselas, la
estimación más baja dice que hay que
15.000, pero algunas
fundaciones quienes aseguran que hay más de
30.000 lobistas, es decir tres veces más
que en Estados Unidos - "Y a esta sala han
venido, los productores, los
agricultores de tabaco canarios a
decirnos que son 3 mil familias que ojo
lo que legislamos, los agricultores no
la Philips Morris. Y os preguntaréis
¿pero realmente tienen tanto poder los
lobbies en Europa?
Bueno, pues juzgar por vosotros mismos: la
Federación Europea de Editores es uno
de los grupos de presión más antiguos
de toda Europa, fue fundado en el año
1967 y engloba a los principales
periódicos de la Unión Europea. No
podemos conocer su presupuesto
económico pero sí se puede ver que han
tenido, en los últimos dos años, más de
20 reuniones con los políticos europeos,
y digo reuniones oficiales porque como
no están obligados a reportar es
posible que hayan tenido otras secretas.
La principal reclamación actualmente es que se saque una ley
que obligue a google a pagar una tasa
especial por poner links de sus noticias
en el buscador, lo que se conoce como la
"tasa google". Parecerá una tontería pero en
España y Alemania ya lo han
conseguido y en Europa parece que no
andan muy lejos.
- "La Comisión Europea ha presentado un
plan para obligar a las compañías de
internet a pagar por enlazar a noticias
online ¡ojo! que no estoy diciendo que
esto sea corrupción, ni siquiera estoy
diciendo que la Comisión Europea, que
sería como el gobierno de Europa, esté
sacando esta ley al dictado de los
lobbies de los editores; es más, estoy
seguro de que han tenido en cuenta
varios puntos de vista.
De hecho pronto vamos a sacar otro
vídeo hablando de cómo las empresas
estilo google están empezando invertir
seriamente en lobbies, pero lo que está
claro es que aquí ha habido una
influencia clara del lobby de los
editores, no sabemos si mucha o poca pero
algo ha habido.
Lo que quería demostraros en el video
de hoy es que el fenómeno del lobbismo
está presente en todo el mundo,
la diferencia es que en Estados Unidos
por lo menos está regulado. Y la
pregunta es ¿creéis que en Europa y en
Latinoamérica tendríamos que poner
regulaciones a los lobbies al estilo de
las que hay en Estados Unidos?
¿Seguís pensando que la democracia
estadounidense está controlada por los
lobbies mientras que vuestro país está
libre de pecado? Podéis dejarme vuestra
opinión en los comentarios.
Personalmente, me parece una pena que los
medios de comunicación apenas hablen de
los lobbies y por eso en VisualPolitik nos gusta tratar estos temas
de vez en cuando. Si os interesa saber
más sobre los lobbies
no olvidéis en suscribiros al canal y
en seguirnos en nuestras redes sociales.
Pero no os vayáis todavía que tengo
una cosa muy importante que deciros
¿Tenéis un grupo de rock? ¿Alguno de
vuestros amigos toca una banda? Pues
mandarnos vuestras canciones a esta
dirección de correo electrónico, si
vuestro estilo encaja con los temas que
tratamos en el canal utilizaremos
vuestra música en nuestros vídeos. Por
supuesto, os citaremos y os daremos toda
la difusión que nos sea posible. Y ahora
sí, si ha gustado este vídeo darle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.